hi there check out these clusters of
images right here and just have a look
at how all of them are pretty much
showing the same object so here's
balloons here's birds here's sharks or
other fish these are from images from
the image net data set and you can see
that these clusters are pretty much the
object classes themselves so there's all
the frogs right here here all the all
the people that have caught fish so this
the astonishing thing about this is that
these clusters have been obtained
without any labels of the image net
dataset of course the data set has
labels but this method doesn't use the
labels it learns to classify images
without labels so today we're looking at
this paper learning to classify images
without labels by water from Guns Becca
Simon Van Daan hender stung stamatis
Georg Ulis mark pro Simmons
and Luke fungal and on a high level
overview they have a three-step
procedure basically first they they use
self supervised learning in order to get
good representations second they do a
clustering so they do a sort of k
nearest neighbor clustering but they do
clustering on top of those things but
they're doing in a kind of special way
and then third they do a refinement
through self labeling so if you know
what all of these are you basically
understand the paper already but there's
a bit of tricky steps in there and it's
pretty cool that at the end it works out
like you just saw so before we dive in
as always if you're here and not
subscribed then please do and if you
liked the video share it out and leave a
comment if you feel like commenting cool
so as we already stated the problem they
ask is it possible to automatically
classify images without the use of
ground truth annotations or even when
the classes themselves are not known a
priori now you might seem like you might
think that this is outrageous how can
you class high when you don't even know
what the classes are and so on so the
way you have to imagine it going forward
and they're sort of they don't
explicitly explain it but it's it's sort
of assumed that if you have a data set
dataset ba-da-da-da-da and you learn to
classify it what basically that means is
you cluster it right you put some of the
data points in in the same clusters okay
and then of course the data set I'm
gonna draw the same data set right here
the same data set would have an actual
classification thing so this would be
class zero this here maybe class one and
this year might be class 2 now you can't
possibly know how the classes are like
called or something which one is the
first which one is a second so at test
time basically if you have a method like
this that doesn't use labels what you're
going to do is you're basically going to
find you're going to be as generous as
possible and in the assignment of these
and say I'll look if I assign this here
to cluster zero and this here to cluster
2 and this year to cluster 1 and I just
you know carry over the labels what
would my accuracy be under that labeling
so you've asked generous as possible
with the assignments of the labels so
that's how it's going to work right
that's a way you have to keep in mind
we're basically developing an algorithm
that gives us this kind of clustering of
the data and then if that clustering
partitions the data in the same way as
the actual labeling would the actual
labeling with the test labels then we
think it's a good algorithm okay so they
claim they have a
okay in this paper we deviate from
recent works and advocate a two-step
approach and it's actually a three step
approach but we're feature learning and
clustering are decoupled okay why why is
that so they argue what you could do
what people have done is and I'm going
to well this is just a wall of text so
what you could do is you could just
basically cluster the data like who says
you can't use clustering algorithms but
then the question is what what do you
cluster them by like you need a distance
so if I have points in 2d it sort of
makes sense to use the Euclidean
distance here but if I have images of
cats and dogs and whatnot then the
Euclidean distance between the pixels is
really not a good a good thing but also
so you might think we could actually we
could you use a deep neural network and
then basically send the image that's the
image right here send the image through
the deep neural network and then either
take this last state right here so it
goes through and through and through and
we could get take either of the hidden
states or we could just take you know
the last state that is the sort of
hidden representation right here and do
the clustering with that but then of
course the question is what do you what
which neural network do you take how do
you train that neural network and there
have been a few approaches such as a
deep cluster which try to formulate
basically an objective for that neural
network where you first you send all the
images through right you send a bunch of
images through to get you in embedding
space you get you points and then in
embedding space you think well the
features that are in the embedding space
they are somehow latent and they you
know if basically the entire thing is if
this neural network was used to classify
images you would have a classification
head on top and a classification head
this is like a five class classification
that is nothing else than a linear
classifier boundary that you put on top
of
this hidden representation so if you
were to use this neural network for
classification it must be possible to
draw a linear boundary between the
classes and therefore the either things
like the inner product distance or the
Euclidean distance must make sense in
that space if they don't make sense in
the picture space but they must make
sense in the hidden representation space
because what you're going to do with
them is exactly linear classification
the last classification head of a neural
network is just a linear classifier so
the assumption is that and the
conclusion is well in this space you
should be able to cluster by Euclidian
distance so what deep cluster does
alternate like is first get the
representations you start off with a
random neural network then cluster these
representations then basically label
self label the images in a way now Oh
way oversimplifying that technique right
here but you have these alternative
steps of clustering and then kind of
finding better representation and then
clustering these representations and
what it basically says is that the CNN
itself is such a is like a prior because
it's the translation invariant works
very good for very well for natural
images the CNN itself will lead to good
representations if we do it in this way
and there's some good results there but
this paper argues that if you do that
then the the algorithm tends to focus a
lot on very low-level features so if the
pixel on the bottom right here is blue
right then you can and the neural
network by chance puts two of those
images where the blue pixel on the
bottom right it puts them close together
then in the next step it will because
they're close together will cluster them
together and then it will basically feed
back the new representation should put
the two in the same class right it will
feed back that it should focus even more
on that blue pixel so it's very very
dependent on initializations
and it can jump super easily onto these
low-level of features that have nothing
to do with what the high level task
you're ultimately trying to solve which
is to classify these images later so
what this paper does is it says we can
eliminate this we can eliminate this the
fact that these methods will predict
will produce neural networks that focus
on low-level features and how do we do
that
we do that by representation learning so
representation you're learning you might
know this as self supervised learning
and this is the task they solve in the
first step of their objective so let's
go through this this right here is an
image now the T is a transformation of
that image and in self supervised
learning there are several methods that
you can transform an image so for
example you can random crop an image you
can just cut out like a piece right here
and scale that up to be as large as the
original image or you can use for
example data augmentation which means
you take the image and you basically so
if there is I don't know the cat right
here you kind of convolve it with some
things it's there's like a very squiggly
cat okay I'm terrible is you can you can
rotate it for example so it's like this
okay so these are all these are all sets
including the crop sets of this
transformation T so you transform it in
some way and you want after you've
transformed it you send your original
image that it should be red you send
your original image and the transformed
image through a neural network each one
by themselves okay and then after then
this you say the hidden representation
here should be close to each other Oh
this is this is basically the self
supervised training task it's it's been
shown to work very very well as a
pre-training method for classification
neural networks you you have an image
and it's augmented version and you
minimize the inner product or the
Euclidean distance between the two
versions in the hidden space and the
rationale is exactly the same the
rationale is that this hidden space of
course should be linearly classifiable
and so the distance between those should
be close and the rationale between
having these tasks is that well if I
flip the image right if I flip the image
to the right it cannot focus on the
pixel on the bottom right anymore
because that's not going to be the pixel
on the bottom right here and I'm not
always going to flip it into the same
direction and sometimes I'm gonna crop
it so it also can't focus on the pics on
the bottom right because in the crop
that pixel is like out here it's not
even in the crop so basically what
you're looking to do with these self
supervised methods is you are looking to
destroy this low level of information
that's that's all you're looking to
build a pipeline of a neural network
here that destroys deliberately low
level information and you do that by
coming up with tasks like this self
supervision tasks that this that
deliberately exclude this information
from being used I think that's what's
going on generally in the self
supervised learning thing okay so this
here as you can see is the neural
network that you train you send both
images the original and the Augmented
version through the same neural network
and then you minimize some distance
which is usually like the inner product
or the Euclidean distance in this
embedding space okay and what you train
you can see right here you train the
parameters of this neural network so the
transformations are fixed or sampled and
the distance is fixed you train the
neural networks such that your
embeddings minimize this task now this
is nothing new this has been this has
been used for a couple of years now to
get better representation self
supervised learning
the thing but they basically say we can
use this as an initialization step for
this clustering procedure because if we
don't do that we focus on these
low-level features okay and notice you
don't need any labels for this procedure
that's why it's called self supervise
okay so the second second part is the
clustering now they cluster but they
don't just cluster these representations
that would be that doesn't perform very
well in their in their experiments what
they instead do is they minimize this
entire objective right here and we'll go
through it step by step so they train a
new neural network okay this thing right
here this is a new neural network so
first you have you already have the
neural network which was called what was
it even called the one that gives you
the embedding with the theta okay it's
called five theta it's the same
architecture and I think they initialize
one with the other so in step 1 you get
Phi Theta 5 theta goes if from from X
gives you a representation of X ok let's
call it hidden X so that's via self
supervised learning but in step 2
you train an entirely new new neural
network this phi ada here and you
initialize it with this one but now you
train it to do the following again you
want to minimize sorry you want to
maximize the inner product right here
see that's the inner product you want to
maximize the inner product between two
things now that's the same thing as
before we want to minimize the distance
between two things and the dot product
distance in that case you maximize the
dot product between two things and the
two things are two images that go
through the same neural network as
before right
this and this now what's different here
is that here
input and one image of the data set
that's the same as before okay so we
input one image but here before in the
self supervised learning we input an
Augmented version of that and now we
input something else we input this K
right here now what's K what K comes
from this neighbor set of X okay this is
the set of neighbors of X and these
neighbors are determined with respect to
this neural network right here okay so
what you do after step one is you take
your neural network with the good
embeddings and here is your data set X
your data set X that's really another
your data set X is this list basically
of all the images in your data set and
what we're going to do is you're going
to take all of them using that neural
network that you just trained and embed
them into a latent space right here okay
this is the latent space where you have
done this self supervised training and
now for each image right here so if this
is X eye you're going to find its K
nearest neighbors and they use I think
they use five as a benchmark so you're
going to find its nearest neighbors it's
five nearest neighbors and you do this
for each image so this image has these
five nearest neighbors and so on so in
step two what you're trying to do is
you're going to try to pull together
each image and its nearest neighbors in
that in this this not in this space
directly but you determine which ones
are the nearest neighbor from this
neural net where can you keep it
constant that's how you determine what
the nearest neighbors are in the first
task and that is your NX set for X I and
in the second step you're trying to make
the representations of any image and its
nearest neighbors closer to each other
okay so with with this thing right here
you maximize the inner product between X
in after this neural network and a
nearest neighbor of X that was was a
nearest neighbor after the first task
now the way they cluster here is not
just again by putting it into an
embedding space like we saw before but
this thing right here this neural
network as you can see here is is a C
dimensional vector in 0 1 now C is the
number of classes that you can either
know that so you don't know which class
is which you don't have labels but you
could know how many classes there are or
you could just guess how many classes
there are and as long as you as you over
guess you can still like build super
clusters later so this they simply say
it's in 0 1 but they also say it
performs a soft assignment so we're also
going to assume that this is normalized
so for each for each data point X here
you're going to you're going to have an
image you're going to put it through
this new neural network ok this new
neural network new and it's going to
tell you it's going to give you
basically a histogram let's say class 1
2 or 3 we guess there are 3 class and
it's going to give you an assignment of
the 3 and you also take a nearest
neighbor here is your dataset you also
take a nearest neighbor of that so you
so you look for this set n of X and you
take a nearest neighbor maybe that's
that's a maybe that's a dog I can't I
really can't draw a dog yeah that's the
best I can do I'm sorry and you also put
that through the same network and you're
saying since they were nearest neighbor
and task 1 they must share some sort of
interesting high level features because
that's what the first task was for
therefore I want to make them closer
together in in the in the light of these
of this neural network right here so
this is also going to give you an
assignment like maybe like this okay and
now you object you you train this
network right here to basically match
these two distributions okay so this is
this is now a classifier into c classes
but we guess c and we don't have labels
we simply our label is going to be my
neighbors from the first task must have
the same labels
that's our label now they say they also
have this term right here which is the
entropy over assignments okay as you can
see so they minimize the following they
minimize this quantity which has a
negative in front of it so that means
they maximize this log inner product and
they also maximize the entropy because
sorry so they minimize this thing and
but the entropy is a negative quantity
right so they maximize the interview
because here is a plus and now they
minimize the entropy let's see what they
say by minimizing the following
objective now entropy is the sum of the
negative sum of P log P and this if this
is P yes this is the probability that an
image is are going to be assigned to
cluster C over the entire dataset so
they're going to mmm yes so it's
negative this quantity negative minus P
log P and this is the entropy so they're
going to minimize the entropy let's see
what they say we include an entropy term
the second term in equation two which
spreads the predictions uniformly across
clusters C ok so what we want is a
uniform assignment over class
which means we should maximize the
entropy oh yes okay they minimize this
thing and this here is the negative
entropy right okay so they want
basically what they want of over the
whole dataset that not all of the images
are going to be in the same cluster well
this is cluster one and then this is
cluster two and then this is cluster
three so that term counteracts that
basically the more evenly spread the
entire dataset distribution is the the
the higher the entropy the lower the
negative entropy and that's the goal
right here I'm sorry this this was I was
confused by the too many negative signs
and then you minimize the entire thing
all right now they say they say
different thing right here they say here
this bracket denotes the dot product
operator as we saw it's the dot product
between these two distributions right
here the first term in equation two
imposes this neural network to make
consistent predictions for a sample X I
and its neighboring samples the
neighbors of X I and here is an
interesting thing
note that the dot product will be
maximal when the predictions are one hot
that means confident and assigned to the
same cluster consistent so they
basically say the objective encourages
confidence because it encourages
predictions to be one hot and it can
Courage's consistency because it you
know that because the distributions need
to be the same they should be in the
same cluster right now I agree with the
consistency like if you make the inner
product high then of the up to date of
two of these histograms of course
they'll look the same right because
these are ultimately vectors these are
three-dimensional vectors let's call
them two-dimensional vectors right so
here is class one here is class two if
you you know make the inner product
small or high they will agree on their
predictions but I I disagree that this
encourages anything to be one hot like
in
and if you have two vectors that are
both zero one times zero one the inner
product is going to be one and if you
have two assignments that are 0.5 and
0.5 then it is also going to result in
an in an inner product of is it 0.5
right is also going to to be no so
what's the inner product here the inner
product is 0.5 times 0.5 plus 0.5 times
0.5 which is 0.5 am i dumb an
embarrassingly long time later oh it's
because the l1 norm okay okay we got it
we got it I am I am okay I am too dumb
yes of course I was thinking of these
vectors being normalized in L 2 space
where their inner products would always
be 1 but of course if you have
assignments between classes and it's a
probability distribution a histogram
then all of the possible assignments lie
on this on this thing right here now the
inner product with yourself of course is
the length of the vector and the length
of a vector that points to one class or
the other class is longer than a vector
that points in between so okay I see
that's where they get this that's where
they get this must be one hot from so
okay I'll give that to them it is
actually encouraging one hot predictions
as long as these things are normalized
in l1 space which they probably are
because they're histograms right yes
that was that was dumbness of me I was
trying to make a counter example I'm
like wait a minute this counter example
is a counter example to my counter
example okay so yeah that's that's that
so as you can see they are of course
correct here and they now
make the first experiments so they say
basically after the first step of the
self supervised training they can
already retrieve sort of nearest
neighbors and the nearest neighbors the
nearest neighbors of these images right
here are the ones that you see on the
right and after the self supervised one
these nearest neighbors are already
pretty good at sharing the high level
features actually crazy-crazy good right
this flute here is in different sizes as
you can see the fishes aren't aren't all
exactly the same the birds so you can
see it really focuses on sort of higher
level of features but I guess it's
really dependent on this higher level
tasks and they what they also
investigate this quantitatively but I
just want to focus on how how good is
this after only the self supervised
thing and now they do this clustering
and they can already sort they could
already evaluate it right here because
now they have a clustering right after
this step they've basically pulled
together the neighbors and they have
this neural network that is not
assigning classes so they could already
evaluate this and they are going to do
that but that's not good enough yet then
they do a third step which is fine
tuning through self labeling now self
labeling is pretty much exactly what
it's what it says it's you label your
own data with your own classifier now
that might be a bit outrageous and you
basically saying wait a minute if I
label my own data and learn a classifier
on these labels isn't isn't it just
going to come out the same and the
answer is no right if you have a dataset
because your classifier doesn't give you
just first of all if your classifier is
something like this right just happens
to be and you label and you learn a new
classifier it is going to be more like
this
right because it sort of maximizes a lot
of classifiers maximize these distances
between the classes so even if it's like
that and then the second step they do is
they say okay there are some points
where we are actually more confident
about such as this one we're more
confident about that one also this one
and then this one here is pretty close
like we're not super neither this one
but we're very confident about these two
so we're only going to use the ones
where we are in fact confident about to
learn to learn the new classifier or
basically we you can also weigh them and
so on but they go by confidence right
here as you can see in this final
algorithm so this is the entire
algorithm and I got kicked away at our
algorithm there we go
all right so semantic clustering by
adopting nearest neighbors they're scan
algorithm so in the first step you do
this pretext task this is the self
supervision the representation learning
okay for your entire data set no sorry
this is this is this your optimized
optimizer neural network with task T
that's just self supervised
representation learning okay then the
second thing we're going to determine
the nearest neighbor set for each X now
they also in that's that they also
augment the data they do a heavy data
augmentation and so on also in this in
the third step in the self labeling they
do date augmentation there's a lot of
tricks in here but ultimately the base
algorithm goes like this so you find
your neighboring sets for each X and
then what you do while you're clustering
loss decreases you update this
clustering neural network by with this
loss that we saw so this is the loss
where you make the nearest neighbors
closer to each other while still keeping
the entropy high
okay and then in the last after you've
done this you go through when you say
while the length of Y increases what's
why why is all the data points that are
above a certain threshold now you going
to filter the data set that is above a
certain threshold and that's your data
set Y and you Terrain this same neural
network you basically fine-tune it with
the cross entropy loss on your own
labels so now you only have labels Y
okay so it's not it's not labels you
have the cross entropy loss between the
assignments of this and the assignments
of your data set okay so you basically
do the same task but you filter by
confidence and they use a threshold
I think of 0.7 or something like this
now let's go into the experiments the
experiments or look as follows so they
do some ablations to find out where in
their methods kind of the the gains come
from and we'll just quickly go through
them if they just do these self
supervision at the beginning and then
just do k-means clustering on top of
that that will give them on C for ten a
thirty five point nine percent accuracy
so not very good so the clustering you
can't just cluster on top of these
representations and then be done if they
do what they say so this is sample and
batch entropy loss this basically means
you do not care about the nearest
neighbors you do this entire thing but
you only make an image close to the
prediction close to itself and it's
augmentations so you don't use any
nearest neighbor information also
doesn't work like I wouldn't pay too
much attention that the numbers are ten
twenty or thirty it just it like doesn't
work
now if you use the scan loss you all of
a sudden you get into a regime where
there is actual signal so this is um
this is now significantly above the this
is significantly above random guessing
and if you use strong data augmentation
as I said is a lot of this is has these
tricks in it of what kind of data
augmentation you do and so on so never
forget that that these papers besides
their idea they put in all the tricks
they can so you get 10% more and then if
you do this self labeling step you get
another 10% more and this is fairly
respectable like 83.5 without ever
seeing labels it's fairly good but of
course there are only ten classes right
here so keep that in mind but they will
do it on image net later and they
investigate what kind of self
supervision tasks at the beginning are
important and they investigate things
like rot net feature decoupling and
noise contrastive estimation which noise
contrastive estimation is the best a
noise contrastive estimation I think is
just where you as we said you input an
image and then it's kind of noisy
versions with augmented in various ways
and then you classify them together and
this has been like this these methods
have been very successful in the last
few years yeah so this they they have
various investigations into their
algorithm I want to point out this here
this is the accuracy vs. confidence
after the complete clustering step so
this is now the third step is self
labeling and you can see right here as
these confidence of the network goes up
the actual accuracy goes up as well so
that means the network after the
classroom is really more confident about
the points that it can classify more
accurately there's like a correlation
between
the network is confident and the actual
label of the point which is remarkable
because it has never seen the label but
also see how sort of the range here is
soup is quite small so with the standard
augmentation that goes like from here to
here so where you set that threshold is
fairly important that might be quite
brittle here because you need to set the
threshold right such that some points
are below it and some are above it and
you you don't want to pull in points
where where you're not because if you
pull in points from here you're only you
only have the correct label for 75% or
something like them of them and that
means if you now self label and learn on
them you're going to learn the wrong
signal so this this step seems fairly
brittle honestly but I don't know of
course they go on and investigate
various things such as how many clusters
do you need or how many nearest
neighbors sorry do you need this number
K here and you can see that if you have
zero neighbors then you're doing a lot
worse than if you have let's say five
nearest neighbors so the jump here as
you can see is fairly high in all the
data sets but after that it sort of
doesn't really matter much so it seems
like five nearest neighbors should be
enough for most things and here they
just show that when they remove the
false positives that their algorithm
actually converges to the correct
clustering the correct accuracy which is
not surprising like if you remove the
wrong samples that are wrong then the
rest of the samples are going to be
right I think that's just showing that
it doesn't go into some kind of crazy
downward spiral loop or something like
this but still it's just kind of funny
okay so they do you investigate how much
they improve and they improve by quite a
lot above the
kind of previous methods so they have a
lot of previous methods but a manner
this includes things like k-means and so
on ganz deep cluster that we spoke about
and this method it already gets as you
can see fairly close to good accuracy so
you have like eighty eight point six
percent accuracy and that's you know
fairly remarkable on C 410 without
seeing the labels but we'll go on and
now they go into image net now image net
of course has way more classes it has a
thousand classes compared to see four
tenths ten classes so if you if you
think you know clustering ten classes
might and they're fairly apart from each
other might work with various techniques
image net a thousand classes that's way
more difficult that I do subsample this
to 50 100 and 200 classes and they get
okay accuracy as you can see they they
get 81 percent in for 50 classes where a
supervised baseline would get 86 percent
into 200 classes they get 69 percent
where a supervised baseline would get 76
percent so it's fairly it's it's there
and and that's quite remarkable for this
low number of classes and they figure
out that if they look for these samples
that are kind of in the most of the
middle of their cluster they get these
prototypes right here you can see all of
these images I don't if you know imagine
that some of the images we really only
have the part of the object and so on so
here with the prototypical things you
really get center clear shot of the
object with clearly visible features and
so on so this sort of re sort of repeats
the fact that this clustering really
does go on what sort of semantic
information
of course the labels here are you know
from the from the test label set the
network can't figure that out and and
then they go for a thousand classes and
in a thousand classes it doesn't really
work because there might be just too
many confusions right here but they do
have this confusion matrix of their of
their method and it shows that the
confusion matrix is pretty much a long
like block diagonal along these super
clusters right here so you can you can
see the dogs the network confuses the
dogs fairly often and then insects with
each other but not really across here
which is still quite remarkable but I
mean that's you get the same thing for a
lot of these methods so I don't know I
don't know how much different this would
be in other methods but certainly it's
interesting to look at now they go into
one last thing and that is what if we
don't know how many clusters there are
right if we don't know anything so say
so far we have assumed to to have
knowledge about the number of ground
truth classes the model predictions were
valid losing the Hungarian matching
algorithm we already saw this in the DET
är by facebook if you remember however
what happens if the number of clusters
does not match the number of ground
truth classes anymore so they now say
Table three reports the results when we
overestimate the number of ground truth
classes by a factor of two okay so now
they build just twenty classes for C for
ten instead of ten classes and we'll
going to look at table three real quick
where's Table three this is Table three
okay so when they over cluster you get
the thing here on the bottom and you can
see there is a drop in accuracy right
here now what I don't actually
they don't actually say how they do the
over cluster matching so if you imagine
if I now have
I don't know six clusters but I any need
to assign them to three clusters you
know here do I still use this most
optimistic thing so they are still used
I think they still use this most
optimistic matching right where you
assign everything to its best fitted
cluster right you compute all the
permutations and then you give it the
best benefit of the doubt now if you
imagine the situation where I over
cluster to the point that I have each
image in its own cluster and I run this
algorithm to evaluate my clustering I
give it basically the most beneficial
view then I would get a hundred percent
accuracy okay so like in in in one of
the in this over cluster approach I
would sort of expect that you actually
get a better score because you can like
there is more generosity of the matching
algorithm involved now that's
counteracted by the fact that you can't
group together things that obviously
have similar features because they are
in the same class so there's kind of two
forces pulling here but I was kind of
astounded that it's going down and the
evaluation method of this matching
algorithm it sort of breaks down when
you have more classes at least in my
opinion yeah but but it's interesting to
see that you can just overshoot and but
then you need some sort of heuristic to
reconcile that in any case I think this
paper is pretty cool it brings together
a lot of things that we're already
present and introduces this kind of this
step approach but what you have to keep
in mind and by the way there's lots of
samples down here what you have to keep
in mind is there are a lot of hyper
parameters in here there are like this
threshold and you know the first of all
yeah the number of classes the
thresholds the architectures and so on
and and all of this
has been tuned to get these numbers
really high right all of these steps all
of the augmentations and so on the
chosen data argumentations it has been
chosen to get this number as high as
possible so you know to interpret this
as oh look we can close classify without
knowing the labels is you know if yes in
this case but the hyper parameter
choices of the algorithm are all
informed by the labels so it is still
very very unclear of how this method
will actually work when you really don't
have the labels when you actually have
to choose the hyper parameters in
absence of anything and yeah I think the
future might tell if they continue to
work on this alright thanks for
listening looking watching and bearing
with me through my wrestling with with
various math basic math in this video I
wish you a good day and bye bye